I'm back [__]
you guys been saying Joey wait we miss
you
you left this out here in the crew
[__] world Joey's back [__] no
worries no tears it's gonna be a good
[__] week if that's not a cloud I
don't know what the [__] is it's a
beautiful day to be alive [__]
the birds are chirpin it's gonna be a
hundred [__] degrees and the
Harvey Weinstein it's still swinging
dick down in Arizona you understand me
it don't matter these [__]
people in Hollywood they're all a bunch
of [__] pukes everybody's acting all
surprised they're all a bunch of
[__] that's why I fly solo
I don't want those [__] my Luc's
around me it's a beautiful day we're
here you're queer uncle Joey's back
[__] if you came out to the shows and
[__] in Lexington Kentucky I love you
[__] solid crowd solid people people
invite me to the house for dinner
old-school America the final
[__] frontier I kept my hats to
your [__] people in Lexington
Kentucky beside that you got the world
by the balls what the [__] you're doing
staring they're looking at me Joey we're
gonna spark what absolutely today I got
that classic oh gee we've just been
killing [__] for two weeks and
I got the hard core from the one eyed
you you know what hardcore means our
core means you might end up in a [__]
alleyway bleeding from your [__] when
you smoke that [__] thank God my
tolerance is up but Joey what's with the
chitchat
oh I love this time when we get together
and spark a number like [__] family
that we are with no [__] friends and
charitable [__] family understand me
you guys think like me I think like you
don't take [__] from nobody especially
on a [__] Monday you gotta set
your marker and enforce it you
understand me because that's what
Mondays are for to lift it every every
week every Monday you gotta lift it
today I got a 10 o'clock
I got jujitsu I got a 3:30 I got a
podcast tonight there's a memorial for
Ralphie May down in [__] Hollywood
tonight I'm passing on it you understand
me you know why because I'm the real
deal Holyfield there's gonna be a bunch
of people in there fake crying make him
believe these are the same people that
talk to bottom believers alive they
could all suck my dick he understand me
I don't do Hollywood [__] funerals
cuz it's all a bunch of their actors
this is what these [__] idiots do so
I'm gonna go down Abbottabad get the
[__] out of here you never cared for the
fat [__] when he was alive now you're
gonna show up [__] these [__] bunch
of hypocritical [__] that's why
we got each other we don't have to act
that way and make believe make [__]
believe you know I'm saying we got
ourselves together we know who the [__]
we are that's a part of these people you
watch on TV yet another [__] they huh
they me like what the [__] is this as
fake as can be a listen you might
disagree admit a lot of points on who
the [__] I am but at least I know what
the [__] I am and I'm not trying to be
thirsting or how the [__] third and
make him believe I'm something I'm not
you understand that drive a [__]
Subaru [__] i stunk with Joey coming at
you on a [__] daily cuz I don't give
a [__] about no behind you a [__] about
the Jones's the Jones's just suck my
dick you understand me this is my
[__] world the same way it's
your [__] world and if you
don't set your [__] land and plant
your [__] flag you're gonna get
[__] all the time
one thing about me is listen you [__] me
I move I don't give a [__] about these
people you got to get up every morning
and sling dig for yourself because at
the end that's you on the [__] casket
with a tuxedo on looking
with no shoes on and who do you know he
was a great man get the [__] daddy
oh thank God for you [__] it's
a beautiful day write your goals do your
push-ups believe in what your [__]
thought is and don't take [__] from
nobody if you believe it deep deep deep
in your heart and you want to do it you
would do it for [__] free you
understand me
you get out there you let [__]
know you ain't [__] around now you're
playing for keeps you ain't no [__]
child
I'll give it back no no you're playing
for keeps [__] and once people
have that then I say [__] about all he's
hard to work no no no this is my world
[__] I do [__] on my [__] terms I
never sold my soul even when I was doing
blow deep and I'm not gonna start now
you understand me [__] you [__]
and that's not you
listen if you leaving the house and you
think you don't thinking somebody's
gonna suck my dick today you're already
[__] slippin it's your day
oh we got a podcast tonight we got a
podcast Wednesday night and then
Saturday night working out with uncle
Joey all the notes I've made from the
road I bring them up on stage and we
talk it's a fifteen dollar ticket at
7:30 on a [__] Saturday night you
still got the night to swing dick and
get your dicks off and do whatever the
[__] you do and that's it let's try some
of this [__] classic Debray put the
day into perspective there's the best
part of my day when I get high with you
[__] because what are you I'd
have dick you understand me without you
I'd have dick and a bunch of oh my god I
didn't want to build that fake I want a
family I want people who are [__]
solid and want people who could talk to
him look in the [__] eye when they
talk to you did not get the [__] out of
my face
Jesus Joseph and Mary
it's 8:30 and I'm already out here
[__] seen the devil two times you
understand up since 6:30 right notes
shower and [__] clean and you know
uncle Joey done whenever we didn't have
a [__] stop there ain't no days off
today's awful but people have credit
card debt you follow me you don't want
credit card debt don't take a [__]
day off that's it and that's that I'll
be around all [__] day but just
remember there's nobody better than you
they can all suck it dick you follow me
if this was Egypt they'd be bowing to
you you better put that in your [__]
head
that's it that's all you need to know I
didn't get my Martella Bing hoy you saw
a pop get word to really hit look at me
see mail from California ayah you saw he
who are some DC metallic boy Obatala and
me see comedian Jemima Mel happen be
there or be square
I love you [__] with all my
rent without you and have you bats stay
black and tell him all the subject a
buyer